I had two fish bowls in my room
and we can calculate you know we know
the average lifespan we know our average
lifespan it's you know whatever the
number is 78 or whatever it is so you
can actually easily calculate the number
of
months weeks or days that you
statistically have left on this planet
right
um and so I bought a bag of marbles and
one marble represented each week that I
have left on the planet
and I filled up the exact number based
on the statistics in one fishbowl
and at the end it's it's more it's more
inspiring than Doomsday
but at the end of every week I would ask
myself was this a week worth living did
I do something to inspire someone
and it's my own standard and if the
answer is yes I move it to the other
Fishbowl if the answer is no I throw
away the marble because I wasted it and
that's why I love the word inspire I
believe it is a standard to live by and
inspiration is what how we make other
people feel